alvin kamara was not pleased at the
suggestion on sunday that the nfl owners
are expected to expand the regular
season to 17 games this week if that was
news to alvin camaro what's he been
doing the last three or four months i
was stunned yesterday that that shifty
tweet was treated as news anyone who's
been paying attention knows it's going
to 17. that was a done deal three months
ago it was already clear peter king
wrote about it several weeks ago what
the formula is going to be for the 17th
game how it's all going to work it's a
done deal but for a lot of these players
now they're waking up to it chris
they're not going to be happy with it a
lot of them voted against the cba from
2020 that gave the nfl the power to move
to 17 games but we all knew this was
coming and we're gonna hit just like
with thursday night football you know
for several years there were complaints
complaints complaints and eventually
they reached acceptance this is just the
way it is and i think that's what's
going to happen here there's going to be
complaints complaints complaints about
17 games and then at some point down the
line there'll be enough players in the
nfl who knew coming in they were signing
up for 17 games that they won't complain
anymore yeah yeah no i mean
first off i think players in general
yeah they don't pay it they hear these
things during the year you know leading
up to last season and all that but they
don't really no they're not in the weeds
like you and me especially with this
specific type stuff sometimes to where
they don't know how real it's getting
but again it speaks to just the bigger
parts of the union a little bit and not
being able to get all on the same page
and understand maybe all the elements of
what you're voting for and doing things
like that all together you know yeah i'm
not a big fan of it i don't want 17
games i don't i i don't and i you know
again i think it's a little hypocritical
and the fact that we're talking about
another game and the playoff the player
safety issues and all that too uh but it
is what it is and you're right we've
known it's coming for a long time and
it's been talked about really for like
the last two years where we thought it's
going to happen at some point in the
next two to three years
but as it relates to player safety and i
know that there could be greater
long-term consequences but short-term
the teams i assume will be responsible
when it comes to how much they work guys
in training camp and in practice and how
much they parse out reps during games
that count how much they use guys in the
preseason they want to protect their
investments short term long term is a
different issue but short term health
and safety it's not like you're going to
treat these guys like rental cars and
drive them into a ditch that they still
have
reason to keep their players healthy
so they're available in the playoffs
roll around yeah i know but so but you
know
but they still need them to get to the
playoffs so there's they're it's not
going to be treated any different it's
going to be like hey we got another game
go smash your head in the wall okay
that's what you paid paid the deal you
know what i don't like is just a little
bit of like the
well i hear this from you know we took a
pre-season game away and added like like
like that was apples to apples oh okay
right you mean you took away the
preseason game for alvin kamara where he
was going to play three snaps and just
do warm-ups and now oh you gave him the
other game and now he's gonna have 55
snaps of running into a middle
linebacker at 4-4 each of them you know
oh great that's good that was an equal
swap no problem so
yes i have an issue with that too not
necessarily with like the short-term
health too either mike it's just like
we've talked about in the past it's you
know another game to get hurt and maybe
not being able to play the next year and
get all the money you might get you know
it might take away another year of your
career all that after a few years of 17
game seasons there's those aspects i
think that don't get talked about in
this conversation enough
i agree with you completely but it's the
reality and
the the supply of potential nfl players
continues to
far outweigh the demand and anyone who
says no they'll be replaced by someone
who says yes that's just the way it's
going and one of the most overlooked
realities of the new tv deals the
ability of the nfl to pull the plug on
all of them after seven years i think
that seven years is where we need to
watch the potential for
18 games when it's time to shop the
the deals again because i firmly believe
the nfl will exercise its right to pull
the plugs and go back to the market and
make more money that's when i think we
need to watch for an 18th game because
they still want an 18th game more
inventory as the gambling spreads and
the money goes up you increase inventory
and once they've increased inventory as
far as they can to 18 chris that's when
expansion is going to start to be a
subject for the nfl with all these young
quarterbacks now who are getting it done
that's the way the ball is moving and
really expansion makes more sense than
increasing the regular season more jobs
more teams same number of total games i
would rather see expansion of the league
than expansion of the regular season you
you would you'd rather see expansion i
got to think about that one for sure i'm
not sure if i would five years ago i
would have said no way but look at how
they're bringing these quarterbacks out
of college they're integrating them
immediately and how effective they are
we don't have the problem that we had
five years ago where there weren't
enough bad quarterbacks to go around now
there's enough good quarterbacks to go
around no i i think that's real too and
you're right there's there's enough good
players to go around and guys that are
backups and things that it could be
league starters and that that yeah we
probably could handle another team or
two in the nfl for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports